foreign
[Music]
this is Dave
he tells jokes for a living
[Music]
I have specials in this many years
how do you close a body of work that
profound the Grammy goes to Equanimity
and a bird Dave Chappelle
I couldn't imagine the enormity of the
pressure
last night Dave Chappelle won the Grammy
award for best comedy album of the Year
defeating fellow nominees Louis CK Jim
Gaffigan Randy rainbow and Patton Oswalt
this marks four consecutive comedy album
of the Year wins for Dave Chappelle
which is just absurd but what's even
crazier is that he's yet to not win a
Grammy for any of his Netflix specials
which have all seemingly been surrounded
in outraged from the mainstream media
are you surprised though by the by the
criticism that's that's come your way no
and I don't mind that that people get
upset some of this criticism is helpful
like I get educated by it I don't
necessarily agree with all of it but I
learned about a lot of things so last
night was the 65th annual Grammy Award
Show apparently all award shows in
general are just a thing of the past at
this point I'm not sure anyone who
actually watches or cares or knows when
these things are even Dave Chappelle
himself wasn't at the Grammys last night
to accept his own award or the one he
won before that uh the Grammy goes to
Equanimity and bird Revelation Dave
Chappelle
foreign
is not here so the academy the academy
accept this on their behalf all right
congratulations although nobody really
gives a [__] about the Grammys it's
still just insane that Dave Chappelle's
been able to win comedy album of the
year every single time he's put a
special out on Netflix that's like an
NFL player coming in the league as a
rookie and winning MVP every single year
he plays for his entire career I don't
even think there is a goat debate
anymore at this point in comedy even
other comedians can't help but call Dave
Chappelle the greatest of all time I
don't give a [__] about these numbers
anything I got Dave
in my opinion
you're the goat in my opinion your last
special
has allowed you to surpass
the Richard Pryor
in my opinion
Dave Chappelle I got to witness
do groundbreaking
controversial
movement as a comedian in the times
where comedy was being frowned upon
comedians were being
held accountable
for doing what we thought we would never
be ridiculed for right the one person
that stood on a pedestal
that got the attention that no others
can get outside of myself a rock
a Seinfeld he said in the time where the
[__] fire is the hottest
I'm going to do
what nobody else will
you gotta [__] applaud that he stood
up for coming he stood up for comedy
whether you want to see that or not
right he did that yes he did it when
there's the most pressure when it was
the most [__] pressure and when the
times of we can cancel you by the way
which is the stupidest [__] that I've
ever
[__] witnessed in my 40 years of life
it's also very refreshing as a comedy
fantasy Dave Chappelle finally getting
some positive recognition from his last
special when the closer first came out
on Netflix everyone deemed it
inappropriate in the mainstream media
and yet again people are trying to
cancel Dave Chappelle which luckily is
impossible even Netflix stood by Dave
side this time and refused to take the
closer off their platform after a bunch
of woke employees threatened to quit
because of the controversial issues in
the closer so that's a huge win for
comedy and a huge win for Netflix
if you do anything wrong you're your
life dull and I find out about it I'm
going to try to take everything away
from you and I don't care what I find
out could be today tomorrow 15 20 years
from now if I find out you're [__]
dude finished
who's that
that's you the closer was nominated for
an Emmy last year and won a Grammy this
year despite the Uproar from people who
have either never watched the special or
just don't understand comedy in general
calling it problematic and transphobic
which really is just a testament to how
truly great Dave Chappelle is as the
late great Norm Macdonald once said in
the war for comedy those with the jokes
will always win Nate progassi's latest
stand-up special hello world came out on
Prime video last week but only if you
live in the United States or UK the
comedian announced on Instagram on
Tuesday that due to technical delays the
special is not in all countries yet but
will be available to stream worldwide on
February 17th everyone I was just
curious how these are titled so hello
world explain the title
uh I just wanted to do like all my
specials uh uh like as far as like the
Tennessee kid and the greatest
African-American were just kind of like
kind of just describing I guess me uh
and so for the hello world was it's a
little not like nod the Tiger Woods like
he said hello world right turn fan I'm a
big golf fan loves Hardwoods uh you know
just trying to be a very welcoming
greeting to try to be like it's just a
special trying to have fun just trying
to be funny besides technical delays
there's been no further update on why
the special is not available in all
places but those who have been able to
watch Hello World seem pretty pleased
with Nate's last hour of stand-up we're
gonna be making a video later this week
collecting comedy fans reactions to the
new special so if you'd like your
comment right on a video just like this
go head over to the joke World Community
section and throw your two cents in then
turn on the post notifications wait a
few days and when a video comes out
titled neparagazi Hello World comedy
fans react that's the one you're going
to want to click on guest spots from
last week your mom's house had on Brian
redband two bears one cave was Burton
Tom and Bert kill Tony tonight is with
Tom Papa flagrant did not have a guess
Ian fight answers on take your shoes off
with Rick Glassman Whiskey's Ginger had
on Steph to live and Dan Soder was on
the Chrissy KS podcast literally so I
would take my daughter my she's one my
little one is one I would drive her to
daycare wait there's a six year
difference between Delilah and her
little sister yeah yeah okay yeah I
thought they were closer to like like in
age no no no Delilah and violent six
years apart
um I think I'm the father of both uh I
definitely Delilah uh and violet too
that's the thing anytime I [__] around
with Jasmine I'm like it's proved to me
that's my kid we how often do you have
that conversation
when I'm drunk
yeah it's like one of those jokey things
that you go I feel like there's Venom
under that yeah it's in my [__] doors
is your [__] Brooklyn Staten Island
yeah you can get to that level The Joe
Rogan Experience talked with Lex
Friedman we might be drunk out on David
Cross Taylor Thomason was a guest on the
blocks podcast with Neil Brennan stavy's
world had a micro scene and Blake
Anderson was on tigerbelly also brand
new try not to laugh Bobby Lee is out
right now on the joke World Main channel
do you know how many animals I have now
no that's also a follow-up four dogs
nice and three cats nice they're in my
freezer I'm gonna have a Barbie girl
I love the delicious
they're delicious as far as new stand-up
goes there's a few specials that have
either come out recently or going to
come out soon we're going to start off
with Sean hamrin he has a new 25 minute
special out right now on YouTube that
was a good funny quick watch also
Roseanne Barr is making her turn to
Comedy next week in a special titled
Roseanne Barr cancel this which will
make a debut on Fox Nation February 13th
and we've already talked about it but
Naper gazi's new special hello world
came out last week in the US and UK and
will be streaming worldwide starting on
February 17th your 30s come and you're
like where are we going
how late are they open is it loud
I am going to drive separate
that does it for this week's joke World
comedy news update as always thank you
so much for watching this video and
we'll be back again next week with some
more comedy news but in the meantime we
got two more videos coming out this week
that I'm really excited to share with
you guys so please make sure you keep
your eye out for that go download this
audio on Spotify or apple wherever you
listen to podcasts and leave in the
comments let me know I want to know how
many times have you won the Grammy for
comedy album of the year
foreign
[Music]